[Música]
y
si todo lo que existe existiendo antes
un pensamiento entonces podríamos decir
que nuestra realidad se basa según lo
que pensamos yo te hago la pregunta
somos lo que pensamos
durante toda mi vida he tenido dudas
acerca de por qué las personas pensamos
como pensamos y en este camino de dudas
e incertidumbre porque me fue llevando
mi vida corta por cierto cortísimo
descubrir una frase de buda que decía
somos lo que pensamos todo lo que somos
se levanta con nuestros pensamientos con
ellos construimos el mundo y yo me quedé
como
entonces dije bueno voy a reflexionar
qué es lo que me quiere decir
y pensando en esto reflexionando me di
cuenta de algunas cosas la primera es
que somos una suma de creencias y
aprendizajes y la segunda es que esta
suma de creencias y aprendizajes son las
que guían la manera en la que tenemos de
observar el mundo
yo te voy a poner un ejemplo porque a mí
me encanta poner ejemplos imaginamos que
vamos
en la calle y hay un choque por nuestro
camino
hay dos clases de personas la primera
persona es la que dice hola cómo quedó
el carro qué mal está tan bonito primera
persona la segunda persona es la que
dice ay ojalá mis hijos paso a una mamá
lo publicitó no dos personas diferentes
dos creencias diferentes dos
aprendizajes diferentes dos formas de
observar diferente pero a esta le vamos
a agregar una tercera sí y esta tercera
es la que emite un juicio no decíamos
que había una que había hecho que mal
como que del carro
otra que había dicho ojalá no se ha
pasado nada y esta tercera dice
y seguramente el que tuvo la culpa fue
el del carro blanco sí sí es que aquí no
saben manejar
claro esta tercera emitió un juicio ya
tiene un culpable en su observadores ya
sabe quién fue el culpable y en su
historia él ya sabe la razón por la cual
choca
y qué pasa con los juicios porque no los
traje este ejemplo nomás para no hablar
de los juicios qué pasa con los juicios
bueno los juicios muchas veces son los
que rigen nuestra vida
y yo te puedo decir si los juicios son
malos o son buenos porque yo no soy ni
psicóloga no soy ni coach no soy una
persona que tiene dudas y que estas
dudas le han llevado a distintos caminos
entonces pues no hay juicios malos o
juicios buenos simplemente hay juicios
muchas veces los juicios te pueden
salvar de alguna mala experiencia pero
muchas veces estos mismos juicios te
pueden privar de buenas experiencias
los juicios te decía yo que la forma en
la que observamos el mundo está basado
en nuestras creencias y nuestros
aprendizajes bueno los juicios es
exactamente igual están basadas en
creencias y aprendizajes pero qué pasa
con las creencias y con los aprendizajes
las creencias y los aprendizajes son
propios y son externos
los propios son los que nosotros
conocemos es decir los que vamos
construyendo nuestra vida por ejemplo yo
hace unos días bueno no hace meses me
abrí la rodilla por ir corriendo en la
lluvia entonces aprendí que ir corriendo
en la lluvia me podía ocasionar un
accidente pero eso lo aprendí yo ahora
están los aprendizajes y las creencias
externas es decir las que alguien más
nos ha enseñado y aquí viene la parte
más lo que todo esto y es que
lo que te han enseñado a ti estas
creencias y estos aprendizajes externos
te los han enseñado tus papás maestros
tus amigos tus en 6 cuanto les quiera
llamar
pero los que ellos te han enseñado
seguramente se los enseñó alguien más
y esta área más lo aprendió de alguien
más y este alguien más de área más y
este alguien más de alguien más y este
bien más de alguien más y estadio y más
de alguien más y así sucesivamente es
decir que lo que tu papá extensión a ti
lo aprenden de sus papás y sus papás de
sus papás de sus tropas de las papas
déspotas de sus papás mis papás de su
país después de sus papás de su papás y
así hasta la prehistoria bueno que me
pase
pero
probablemente tú tengas creencias y
aprendizajes de personas que ni siquiera
conoces que ni siquiera tuviste el honor
de compártelos en la vida
y ya sé lo que están pensando es decir
este no es el momento para ser el árbol
genealógico no lo es no lo es
es el momento de preguntarnos entonces
quién soy yo realmente porque me doy
cuenta que mis conocimientos mis
aprendizajes mis creencias pues muy mías
muy mías quizás no son no yo te decía
que son una suma de creencias y
aprendizajes compartidos
entonces este es el momento de hacer la
pregunta más grande quién soy yo en
realidad
quienes estamos siendo que estoy
pensando si este pensamiento es mío o es
de alguien de hace mucho tiempo
entonces
yo te decía que los juicios de valor son
aquellos que rigen nuestra vida
muchas veces no se van a tomar
decisiones no buenas ni malas
simplemente decisiones entonces en este
momento en este momento si nos ubicamos
en tiempo y espacio
el día de hoy va a haber nueve mujeres
privadas de su libertad
y legalmente 3.5 millones de niños
terminando su jornada laboral y no
escolar
bar 17 personas que se van a intentar
quitarse la vida y muchas de ellas
seguramente van a tener éxito
y eso solamente va a pasar aquí en
méxico
y va a haber alguien una persona que se
va a tomar el tiempo de emitir un juicio
de valor acerca de estas problemáticas
solamente solamente conociendo una parte
de la historia una cara de la moneda y
la moneda siempre tiene dos caras
entonces para empezar a transformar
nuestro entorno para empezar a
transformar nuestro mundo para empezar a
transformarnos a nosotros
tendríamos que empezar también a
transformar un poco quienes somos
es momento de empezar a hacer
disruptivos y decir bueno
quién soy qué es lo que estoy pensando y
lo que estoy pensando está ayudando me
está ayudando en este momento estoy
dando al mundo
a nuestro entorno
una vez mi mamá hace muchos años
me dijo peter tú quieres cambiar el
mundo pero no puedes ni entender la cama
cuando terminas de despertar
ahí yo entendí muchísimas cosas
y es que si nosotros queremos cambiar el
mundo lo podemos hacer pero este cambio
tiene que ser
de nosotros también entonces hay una
frase que una amiga me dijo pequeñas
personas haciendo cosas pequeñas pueden
cambiar
y no sé si nosotros empezamos con
pequeñas acciones
si nosotros empezamos a detener nuestros
pensamientos que vienen les decían que
nuestros pensamientos vienen desde hace
mucho son creencias y aprendizajes que
hemos aprendido desde hace mucho si
nosotros ponemos un alto y empezamos a
construirlos y empezamos a hacer un
cambio en nuestra manera de observar el
mundo probablemente va a haber un cambio
en el mundo
así que yo te dejo con la siguiente
pregunta
quién quiere ser tú en realidad
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]